buenas qué tal estáis oye porque hay
personas que sin medios económicos ni
materiales son capaces de encumbrar sus
sueños porque hay personas que piensan
en una meta o tienen un objetivo y da
igual el tiempo que les lleve al final
son capaces de conseguirlos
qué rabia dan porque hay personas que no
se paran a pensarlo y que directamente
se enfocan en ello estas personas tienen
un nombre son líderes no nosotros la
llamamos así son personas de éxito
porque a cualquier nivel sea económico
personal ya han conseguido ser exitosas
laboral del tipo que sea pues todas
estas personas tiene una cosa en común y
es que estas personas conocen
perfectamente toda la energía que tienen
son muy conocedoras de su propia energía
y además tienen el valor y la fortaleza
de perseguir su instinto
y es que cuando tú creas algo nuevo pues
siempre
es horrible porque es muy muy muy
desgastante pero a la vez la sola
posibilidad de que eso se pueda llegar a
cumplir es sublime las cosas la gente
que tenemos sueños y tenemos algo por lo
que pelear realmente sentimos una
energía muy bestia y sentimos fuego en
las manos
y esto no es una simple creencia todo
esto tiene una base científica estos dos
conceptos son los que hacen que las
personas sean líderes y exitosas
instinto y energía y como os he dicho
antes todo esto tiene una base de
científica y de audiencias del deporte y
bueno ciencias del deporte aunque no lo
creáis se estudia la ciencia y siempre
he dicho que si tuviera que volver a
elegir no volvería a escoger de ideas
del deporte porque me encanta la
comunicación me encanta hablar y sin
embargo no me arrepiento para nada
porque gracias a que hice esta carrera
he comprendido aspectos esenciales que
me han llevado a estar donde estoy hoy
en día y es que he comprendido cuál es
el funcionamiento de la energía algo que
yo ya he sentido toda la vida por dentro
le he podido dar una explicación y es
que cuando
cuando tú conoces cómo funciona o de qué
está compuesto el cuerpo humano
realmente empiezas a entender la energía
nosotros estamos compuestos de materia
esa materia está compuesta de células
esas células a su vez están compuestas
de moléculas y finalmente tenemos la
unidad más pequeña que es el átomo la
unidad más pequeña que se creía de la
que estábamos hechos hasta el siglo 20
que se quería de que estamos hechos era
el átomo el siglo 20 se descubre que no
que esos átomos de los que estamos
compuestos comunidad más pequeña a su
vez tienen un núcleo y dentro hay
protones y neutrones tú te lo sabes
protones y neutrones y alrededor de él
giran electrones y qué es lo que hace
que esas partículas no se dispersen
simplemente energía y aquí viene lo
bello de la cuestión y es que lo que une
dos átomos son simplemente vibraciones
de energía vibraciones de energía es más
lo que lo que une la unidad más pequeña
de lo que nosotros somos es energía y
esto es ciencia no es algo que nos hemos
inventado o sea que realmente nosotros
por dentro desde el principio somos
energía es más dos de los átomos más
importantes y esenciales para la vida
son energía oxígeno sabéis la cantidad
de veces que respiramos al día 21 mil
respiraciones al día porque nosotros
respiramos entre 5 y 6 litros por minuto
y eso en 24 horas que son ahí lo tenéis
entre 7200 y 8.200 respiraciones en 24
horas imaginaos la energía de la gente
que es consciente de llevar una buena
respiración
la gente que es capaz de manejar su
respiración es capaz de manejar su
energía y esto es muy del líder esto es
muy de persona exitosa si utilizamos dos
moléculas de hidrógeno y lo unimos a una
de oxígeno tenemos el 60 por ciento de
nuestra composición corporal agua
esencial para la vida no hay no hay vida
si no hay agua porque fijaos qué curioso
que nuestro cerebro funciona al 83% con
agua nuestra sangre el 94% y todo eso es
energía que nosotros tenemos y que no
somos consciente aquel que no se hidrata
bien aquel que no como bien no tiene
energía aquel que no respira bien no
tiene energía
el otro concepto que nos hace líderes es
ser muy muy conscientes de nuestro
instinto y tener el valor de perseguirlo
el instinto es aquello etimológicamente
que proviene de dentro por el prefijo in
y el verbo instituyera porque viene del
latín esto me lo aprendido
significa pinchar y empujar en pulsar
empujar empujar impulsar vale pero
además biológicamente el instinto es
aquella pauta hereditaria que va a hacer
que
que sea común a todas las especies y que
hace que las especies prevalezcan y la
biología reconoce estas dos instinto de
supervivencia el instinto de
supervivencia y el instinto de
reproducción así que todas estas
personas que me dicen
no hay es que eso del instinto no tengo
instinto yo hablemos de sexo
si tienes sexo tienes instintos sin
meter emociones
si tienes sexo tienes instinto luego
porque nos resulta tan difícil
comprender que el instinto
o sea el instinto porque no resulta tan
fácil comprender el instinto primario
para la reproducción y para salvarnos y
para correr y porque nos resulta tan
difícil comprender el instinto en las
acciones secundarias en aquellas que no
son primarias porque nos resulta tan
difícil pues nos resulta de súper
difícil porque hay que tener mucho valor
y porque tenemos muchos miedos el miedo
bloquea el instinto el miedo bloquea el
instinto y esto las dudas esto es algo
muy del líder el objetivo es tan grande
que apenas tienes miedo
y de esto saben mucho los alpinistas los
alpinistas como georg valor y os invito
a que leáis
un libro que se titula los
conquistadores de lo inútil de lionel
terray y ahí george valor y no sabéis es
uno de los primeros que intentó subir al
everest murió en el descenso entonces no
se sabe a ciencia cierta si llegó hasta
arriba pero el alpinismo
es una de esas razas de personas que
persiguen mucho su instinto y realmente
pensar en el beneficio que van a obtener
a cambio están apostando la vida pero al
final consiguen grandes cosas porque el
alpinismo no es solo ego el alpinismo es
exploración el alpinismo es la búsqueda
es ciencia también vale entonces georg
valor y cuando le preguntaron por qué
escalar montañas él dijo
porque están ahí
fijaos qué sencillo o sea qué acción más
sencilla porque están ahí es que no hay
no hay una lógica a veces para hacer las
cosas no hay una lógica que explique por
qué hacemos las cosas cuando sabemos que
debemos hacerlo y éstas y muchas otras
cosas aún se le escapan a la ciencia
pero debemos saber que existen y que
están ahí y que nos están ahí para
hacernos muy muy muy muy poderosos
entonces instinto o razón
albert einstein dijo jamás he tenido una
sola d
mis creaciones de mis ideas simplemente
actuando con mi mente racional así que
no se trata de desterrar la razón para
perseguir el instinto no sé si sabéis
que que en la naturaleza en la
naturaleza
nos ha diseñado por pares hay una cosa
que se llama el bilateralismo
biológicamente los biólogos lo saben
verdad el bilateralismo nos han creado
con dos ojos y dos orejas dos oídos para
que podamos tener una visión este una
una visión
tiene una visión y una audición que nos
permita tener una una percepción
profunda de las cosas nos han creado con
dos piernas y nos han creado con dos dos
brazos mucho más sutiles que cuatro
piernas y que cuatro que cuatro patas y
además nos han creado con dos cerebros
el cerebro lógico y el cerebro
creativo el cerebro intuitivo y el
cerebro racional
y la combinación e integración de ambos
nos hace súper potentes normalmente sólo
utilizamos uno de nuestros cerebros
porque nos han enseñado no es que yo soy
más racional no ya es que soy súper
visceral tenemos los dos y normalmente
sólo actuamos con uno de ellos imaginaos
el potencial que nos estamos perdiendo
así que
eres una persona de esas piensa en esto
vale albert einstein ideó la teoría de
la relatividad imaginando que viajaba
sobre un haz de luz
esto implica que todas las teorías que
tenían primero eran una idea que él
imaginaba que podía ser algo instintivo
él creía que podía ser una hipótesis
y al final las estas teorías las sometía
a la más absoluta
ciencia para poder ver si podía
verificar las o refutar las pero todo
esto nacía de la integración de estos
dos cerebros de inicialmente una idea
que era muy instintiva
y cuando concluimos estos dos conceptos
valen
energía
e instinto nos hacemos súper poderosos y
podemos tener la capacidad de encontrar
lo que los japoneses llaman el liquigás
el liquigás es nuestra razón de ser y
nuestro motivo para estar en el mundo
según los japoneses y según esta teoría
todas aquellas personas o todos aquellos
seres desde el mismo momento de la
concepción tienen un motivo de ser en el
mundo por pequeño que sea y bajo mi
punto de vista
es emotivo común a todos es dejar este
mundo un poco mejor
es que no hay otro motivo no puede haber
otro motivo porque no habéis sentido que
cada vez que hacéis algo positivo sentís
como un fuego dentro y sentís que es
increíble es que ese es el motivo común
a todos pero luego además
tienes que encontrar tu propio camino
para mí y que guy no es sólo tu motivo o
tu razón de ser porque para mí el motivo
está muy claro para mí y además es cuál
va a ser la vía para que tú te vayas de
este mundo dejando una huella positiva
qué energía tiene el cambio qué energía
cuando encuentras a alguien que te ayuda
a cambiar cuando encuentras a alguien
que te ayuda a tener el valor de
perseguir tu instinto de aprender de
tener sueños de encontrar el camino de
encontrar tu iquique energía tiene el
cambio y ella
increíble tiene muchísima energía se
llama odilo char y es el ejemplo de todo
esto que estaba contando para mí es una
líder es muy fácil poner a albert
eistein a steve jobs y toda esta gente
que tiene muchísimo éxito pero ella es
una súper súper súper líder se llama de
luchar me la encontré en el hard maratón
de sables de perú es una carrera porque
muchos transmitidos en este mundillo es
una carrera que son 120 kilómetros en
completa autosuficiencia se corre en
tres etapas atravesando las dunas del
desierto de ica en perú
ella tiene actualmente 61 años y es
completamente ciega desde los 15
empezó a correr a los 45 y cuando yo me
metí en su tienda ella me contaba que
era la segunda de 13 hermanos en el cine
había estado toda la vida trabajando y
cuando empezó a correr de repente ese
cambio empezó a generar cambios en su
vida y a la vez cambios en todas las
personas que estaban a su alrededor y
empezó a notar la energía de ese cambio
y encontró su big y guy week y guy y su
razón de ser en este mundo es
demostrarle a todo el mundo que si
persigues tu instinto y tienes el valor
y la energía para hacerlo
finalmente puedes hacer todo lo que te
propongas cualquier cosa 45 años a los
45 años empieza con 61 años acaba el
maratón de sables de perú y os digo más
me contó perfectamente
como era el desierto ella había
muchísimo más que yo porque vio cada
piedra vio cada duna y vio cada rayo de
sol a través de los ojos de todos los
compañeros que se cruzaron en su camino
así que si vais por ahí y no tenéis
alguna energía y no tenéis aún el valor
para perseguir vuestro instinto estad
atentos porque hay mucha gente que es el
ejemplo de la energía que genera el
cambio
el sol se fue
y con él las chicas de sangres
regresaron a sus tiendas
[Música]
para el día siguiente
volver a la batalla
nuestro mujeres de todas partes del
mundo han venido aquí con una misión muy
importante
hacer tu ejemplo
[Música]
en el ejemplo del cambio
para que entiendas que eres el mensaje
infinita
[Música]
ah
no es ilusión es ciencia lo tenéis
dentro utilizad lo toda la energía
si no la tenéis vosotros coge toda la de
los demás ellas son el ejemplo son el
ejemplo de que podemos hacerlo y de que
lo vamos a hacer vamos a irnos de aquí
dejando este mundo un poco mejor tener
el valor perseguir vuestro instinto y
dejar huella
i